good morning John today I have a very
special encounter to share with you late
last night a creature happened upon my
camp a creature of such eccentric
peculiarity and uniqueness that all were
taken aback by its presence it is the
dan brow and though the Dan Brown's odd
behavior has been well documented in its
natural habitat here we have some of the
first footage ever captured of the Dan
Brown outside of his natural habitat
though most of the Dan's time seems to
be spent in a sedentary sitting position
poking at this antique instrument of his
the one you see here I believe is from
2007 the Dan will occasionally break
from this sedentary life and suddenly
will be performing one of his many
bizarre displays the function of these
displays has been debated for decades by
scientists studying the Dan son believed
the displays exist to attract a mate
though there is strong evidence that the
displays have in fact had the opposite
effect others believe that the Dan is
scratching some subconscious itch that
can only be reached by mastering complex
yet meaningless activities whatever the
case the displays of the Dan are
breathtaking and their visual and
auditory complexity John I know you know
who Dan Brown is but there may be some
people watching this who do not know who
Dan Brown is he is not the guy that
wrote The Da Vinci Code dan brunt of the
video blogger very similar to Aussie is
a similar style and similar values to us
which makes him kind of a kindred spirit
that he's got a color for a last name -
but it's not green so he's not our
brother but he is Dan Brown so then has
just started this project the idea of
the project is that he is giving over
his life to the people who watch him
he's letting his community kind of
decide what he should do for the next
year of his life whether it's little
projects like write a letter to the
President or bigger projects like fly
out to Missoula Montana and record a
song with Hank green that idea was
suggested by me and it roasts the top of
his decision engine and
then like a week later he was at the
Missoula Airport and I went and picked
him up pretty freaking cool actually I
think Dan three-pointer was fascinating
for like 20 different reasons and some
of those 20 reasons are reasons why I
would never want to do this but some of
the 20 reasons that reasons why I would
really like to lots of people are kind
of treating it like it's a cute stunt
for a guy to do for a year I'm talking
to Dan and I hope he doesn't mind if I
say this it's clear that Dan Brown
doesn't know what to do with his life
and I think a lot of us don't know what
to do with our lives and that's really
scary and it feels like other people
have got it all figured out but they
don't and once you do know what you're
doing with your life it's really boring
trust me I'd been there and then it's
convinced that the people who watch him
his community will make better decisions
than he would on his own so in effect I
think Dan is doing what a lot of us wish
we could do would just say help me
figure out what to do with this anyway
happy left-handed day I'm not
left-handed personally but I had a
teacher in middle school one of my
favorite teachers of all time she grew
up in Czechoslovakia went to Catholic
school and they beat her for being
left-handed and she wrote with her right
hand her entire life because of this so
if ever you left-handers feel oppressed
just think of mrs. Maria and another
handedness related side note I could not
tell my right from left until I was
about nine due to a learning disability
that I have but then when I was nine I
cut my hand on a piece of terracotta
pottery it did some nerve damage it
severed tendon and to this day it's
constantly it never stops aching but
because I have this permanent pain in my
right hand I always know that the one
that hurts is the right and so now I
know my right from that hooha
nerdfighters John I will see you on
Monday